so the earth Institute is a unique part
of this University and fairly unique
structurally in the Academy and the way
I sometimes explain it is if you think
about Columbia University which for
America is an old University starting in
1754 when it first started there were
about four academic departments history
philosophy science things like that
American higher education evolves
through the 19th and 20th century just
as social needs changed so you see the
beginnings of medical school of law
school all designed to deal with
specific problems our engineering school
used to be called the School of Mines
and it was created because they couldn't
figure out how to dig the subway tunnel
in Manhattan and so they actually
created a school to deal with those
problems it was called the School of
Mines as people like Mike crow who was
really the founder of the earth
Institute started to think about the
issue of global sustainability it was
pretty clear to us that the school
structure the departmental and school
structure of the university was
insufficient that we needed actually in
dealing with the issue of sustainability
we need to be able to draw on
engineering and law and public health
and economics and public policy and an
environmental science and ecology in
very fundamental ways and we needed
something that was above Department and
above schools to be the integrative
force and that was the Earth Institute
so the earth is - is the largest
Institute at Columbia it's the only one
that reports directly to the Provost and
it's really a university-wide enterprise
unlike any school at Columbia I'm the
chief operating officer I worked for
Jeff Sachs who's our visionary so he
gives the vision I actually have to make
sure the place runs
I'm the management professor so we get
about 11 million dollars a year directly
for the president and the center of the
University no school gets that that
would be the equivalent of a 200 million
dollar endowment and so the Columbia
University since the mid-90s has been
spending roughly that much money on this
place in addition to the other things
that we
and I should say that the scientific
hard the Institute is the lamont-doherty
Earth Observatory now Lamont is a campus
30 miles north of New York City that is
four times the size of this campus and
we have 500 Earth Institute people there
the Earth Institute is about 750 people
and about 140 million dollar a year
operation in contrast the school of
international public affairs is less
than half that size in its dollars and
and staffing is a little hard to compare
research to to teaching an enterprise in
any event within the earth Institute
then we have what are called
cross-cutting initiatives energy water
hazards food poverty urbanization it's a
whole range of them and we've created
research units in every one of those
areas we have the LED fest Center for
sustainable energy headed by Klaus
Lackner we have the Columbia water
senator headed by OMA allow the the
Columbia climate center headed by Peter
schlosser we have a whole variety over
two dozen of these research units on
practically every issue of
sustainability and then we have
something called the Earth Institute
faculty which is two dozen tenured
professors in the head of our major
units that meet together and set policy
for the whole Institute so this is a
very unique enterprise the last thing
I'd say about is we also unlike most
research institutes of Columbia do not
get heavily involved in education the
Earth Institute has started over half a
dozen new education programs in the last
two years for example we started an
undergraduate major in sustainable
development the Masters of science and
sustainability management earlier we
started the MPA and development practice
the MPA and environmental science and
policy the Masters in climate society
and of course the PhD in sustainable
development so this is a very unique
part of the University very creative and
unlike the rest of the university where
everything is you know the management
term is stovepipes
everybody stays in their own place the
Earth Institute is a Jag
antek integrative enterprise very unique
for colombia very unique for American
higher education and really a very
exciting place to be and so a few years
ago the some people started to ask me
well is sustainable development feasible
and there was a whole project of us
trying to work on that and I decided
halfway to the project even though the
that project didn't really resolve
itself successfully that we really have
no choice but make it feasible
it's either either sustainable
development feasible or we're all dead
and so I have this belief that our
species is not suicidal it's just a
belief but I really think it's true and
so I decided to conceptualize
sustainability as a management issue not
as an issue of necessarily of policy or
anything else but to really think about
what kind of human activities are
necessary if we're going to get to
sustainability so I'm gonna try to go
through this is my new book I'm going to
go through this rather quickly so that
we have some time for a discussion so
this is the Express train version of my
book talk ok so what's the goal of
sustainability management I'm trying to
figure out how organizations can
contribute to global sustainability to
answer the question can we grow our
world economy and open up opportunity
the pores the pores and manage to keep
the planet intact and here's the problem
7 billion people on the planet now
probably growing to 10 billion China and
India and eventually Africa are going to
consume as much as the rest of us do
today so how do we keep the planet
intact with that level of consumption
now there are some people who think you
don't have to get to that level of
consumption but I'm a political
scientist and I can tell you that
everybody in the world wants what we
have they want the cars they want the
iPods they want the laptops they want
the air conditioning they want the wine
and they're gonna get it one way or the
other either they're going to take it
from you or we're going to figure out
some way of
of bringing it about in a peaceful way
so that's so my hope is that we actually
figure out a way to do this so the idea
behind the book is to survey the concept
of sustainability and then think about
the different arenas of organizations
and then of the issue of energy water
food and then move up several units of
analysis to cities as integrative
systems and planning I basically look at
each of those issues and say what are
the technological challenges is what
don't we know yet what are the financial
organizational and management challenges
how do we get the capital one of the
issues that I'm always worried about is
how do we get people who were in
organizations to know how to do these
things you know we might develop all
sorts of technology and all sorts of
methods but in the end it's a human
being and a bunch of human beings
together in organizations that make
these things happen and and my my focus
on management it really comes out of my
time at EPA when I worked in the
underground storage tank program in
America at 1985 40% of every underground
storage tank for gasoline was leaking
we're now down to about 8% but you know
it's one thing for a waste to to escape
into the environment but this is the
stuff they sell okay and they know how
to keep the gasoline inside the
underground tanks there's lots of
technology for that so why don't they
use it and I mean some of it the answer
is economics the gasoline is just too
cheap but some of it is basically
management problems the people working
at gas stations don't care so how do you
figure out a way to bring that basic
behavior down to the level of
implementation which is always one of
the issues that I worry about so I
define sustainable sustainable
development the same way the Brundtland
Commission did and sustainability
management is basically the use of
organizational management practices to
result in sustainable development I mean
sustainable development a wonderful
concept but the end it's going to be
organizations and it's going to be
people in organizations that make these
things have
so what are the characteristics well one
of the characteristics is thinking in
the long term instead of focusing on
weekly quarterly and daily reports now
the problem here is that because
informations gotten so cheap and
communications is getting so cheap our
managers now have real-time information
on organizational performance and
they're obsessed with it
okay you know you hear about what we
call the CrackBerry the blackberry
they're always you know batteries are
always looking at those devices half the
time they're making decisions while
they're playing squash or they're
jogging because they're they basically
never stop thinking about what they're
working in
there's no time to step back and reflect
the sustainability requires stepping
back and reflecting but this information
age is affecting management by giving us
information on a moment-by-moment basis
and we're all addicted to it you know I
mean I kept my my iphone over there and
I'm getting a little nervous here
something might happen in the earth
Institute that I need to keep track of
there's another concept of management
that I talked about in the book which is
that the field of management itself has
been evolving through the 20th and now
21st century so it starts the field
itself in some respects starts with mass
production and time motion studies and
people with stopwatches trying to figure
out scientifically can we get production
lines to work better and then you end up
with the human relation school of
management where they figure out that
observing workers no matter what you did
you could turn the air up you could turn
the air down the lights on the lights
out it doesn't matter the thing that had
the greatest effect on workers
productivity was the fact they were
being observed and so that creates a
whole different sequence and growth of
the fields of management the way from
the Mormon echinus t'k to a more organic
view of organizations as living and
breathing entities so you see that of
evolution then you see the development
of accounting I mean believe it or not
generally accepted accounting practices
are less than a century old and so we
see that developing then in the 1960s
we're computing comes in we see the
development of information management
and performance measures first used very
badly Robert McNamara used them
effectively at Ford but then decided to
try to translate that to the war in
Vietnam and thought that body counts was
a good measure of success for the war so
some of the early efforts that had
management like this didn't work that
well but there have been refinements one
is it here in New York City we have
something called CompStat which measures
crime in the 90s we had 2,200 homicides
in New York City
last year we had less than 500 so that's
a in part one of the reasons for that
success there are a lot of reasons we
were one of it is that we now measure
crime in real time through a system
called CompStat and so the people so we
now send police to where the criminals
are instead of protecting rich people's
houses on Park Avenue this this was this
is something a management change that
was only possible with the advent of the
Information Age so you see information
growing then you see at the beginning of
the 21st century at the end of the 20th
century the global corporation every
corporation suddenly had an
international desk those corporations no
longer have international desks because
everything is global ok so the next
stage of evolution I believe is
sustainability every organization every
CEO is starting to think about what are
my resources energy and water waste
pollution they're starting to think
about that in the same way they think
about production and labor and capital
because it's becoming a bigger and
bigger input into management
decision-making and so the way I look at
it is the issue of sustainability is
going to enter routine decision-making
just as international and information
and accounting did in previous times so
this is simply another stage in the
evolution of the more sophisticated
organization the CEO is gonna have to
think about physical physical issues
that they never had to think about
before so is it feasible I asked that in
the book can we manage our way to
sustainability is there enough capacity
to produce the food energy water air and
biological necessities that we need I'd
say right now
we don't know how to do this but we
better figure it out and I actually
believe we will figure it out because
the history of human evolution is that
we gradually figure these things out
you know Malthus said we would all be
starving by now but technology
intervened and we created a different
kind of world
there was a book I was reading a book
reviewers reading the New York Times
which said over the weekend that wealthy
people 400 years ago live worse than
poor people live today that the standard
of living of the planet has grown the
issue of survival of saying warm and
having enough food and having shelter
and not being killed by the enemy
storming the gates is no longer a
day-to-day concern of most people and
that's part of why I think we will
figure this out
but we need natural resources technology
and management organizational capacity
so one of the prerequisites to
sustainability well first of all we
better figure out how to stop blowing
ourselves up a couple of dirty bombs in
Times Square or in the center of London
or Paris and all bets are off because
then we're going to have something that
I don't even want to think about and
it's not unimaginable that that could
happen New York City has a thousand
police officers working on
counterterrorism they're spending
billions of dollars to try to keep the
city safe and I know that that's
happening in other cities around the
world right now population in poverty we
have to have a demographic transition
for the whole world we have to get to
the point where where people aren't
having children because they think it's
going to help protect them in old age or
because they're worried about their kids
died due to infant mortality we know
that as people get wealthier they have
fewer children that's going to happen in
the rest of the world also but we have
to do it in time to cap the population
at about ten billion and then of course
there's energy you know in the end
fossil fuels are will probably never run
out because there's an economic function
they really can't they'll get too
expensive before you
they run out but the point is that
fossil fuels are a one-time resource on
the planet and they are going to get
more expensive and more difficult to get
out of the Earth's crust and so at some
point there's going to be a tipping
point where renewable energy sources are
going to have to replace fossil fuels as
energy sources energy itself is the
single most important sustainability
issue you solve the energy issue you
solve the whole it the whole issue but
we have to figure out how to reduce our
ecological footprint we have to figure
out how to not damage the basic systems
that provide us with air and water we
are all biological creatures we need
water
we need to drink we need to drink water
we need to breathe air we need to eat
food and to the extent those things are
contaminated with poisons from our
production process it's not healthy for
us let's put it that way so there are
technical managerial and political
challenges for sustainability for water
we need to figure out a way to
distribute and reprocess water this is
again where energy is so useful if you
know if desalinization really becomes
feasible it's only becomes feasible as
energy prices become lower relative to
other parts of our economic wealth and
there's plenty of order on the planet
and we the water never leaves the planet
it just gets degraded in different ways
and sometimes it's in the wrong place
for our needs and so water in some
respects is the ultimate management
problem okay waste we have to learn how
to clean sewage and other waste treating
it as a reusable commodity instead of
simply a residue so waste-to-energy
anaerobic digestion that our recycling
products that go back and to reuse them
in Xerox makes a copier where 80% of the
copier at the end of the lease goes back
to the company and they can reuse it in
the next generation of copiers that kind
of closed system engineering has to
become more typical food you know I get
a lot of people a lot of my students
think that every all the food should be
grown by local farmers
and we should all eat organic food and I
I wish that we could I know the person
that runs New York's green markets we
have these stands all over the city and
I said why don't you expand this why
don't you get some more of these and he
said we're out of farmers every farmer
within 150 miles in New York City is
selling everything they grow in those
green markets okay and it only provides
5% of the of the food for the city
without industrial farming this city
couldn't exist and the planet would
start and so we have to figure out a way
to make industrial farming more energy
efficient more water efficient and less
polluted in America you know we still
have this mythology of the family farm
so the farms have largely escaped
regulation under the basic environmental
regulations because everybody has in
mind that it's some it's some family on
a farm not some huge industrial feedlot
where they've got thousands upon
thousands of pigs and cows and chickens
so the image of of how people get their
food and the real situation are
radically different the other thing that
we need to do is we need to learn how to
measure the planet's conditions now of
course here I am a lobbyist I run the
Earth Institute but the degree to which
our basic observations of air and water
and ground and the fundamental
conditions of the planet we don't
understand we don't really understand
long-term climate we don't really
understand where the next earthquakes
are coming from we have it lamont a
group of several dozen seismologists and
they're very good at studying and
understanding earthquakes but they
really still can't predict where and
when they're going to happen someday we
should be able to do that use the same
things true climate we can predict the
long term ten years from now the basic
trends of climate and we certainly have
studied the past very effectively but
tell me whether it's going to rain a
week from now I can't and neither can
the scientists here
all of these kinds of technologies that
need to be brought in and developed
require government intervention the
America you've probably heard from Bob
Shapiro earlier today is becoming a very
polarized country and the idea of
government investment in infrastructure
or basic research and development which
is a function only government can
perform is something that is is under
challenge right now now the United
States has this wonderful system of
research universities which is an
incredible resource for developing basic
science but we're unable to get it done
now there are lots of examples in
American history of the basic science
coming out of a partnership largely
between universities and the military so
I mean the internet started as a Defense
Department project to share data across
their computers
I mean laptop computers are probably one
of my favorite examples why did they
shrink the computer when I was in
graduate school the computer I used was
the size of this room okay and it had
less computing power than my iPhone has
why did they shrink it they shrank it
for only one reason to put it on
missiles to help the guidance systems
and eventually to put that into manned
spacecraft they needed to make those as
light as possible and that created the
dynamism behind shrinking the computer
and then a guy like Steve Jobs would
look at that and say hey this could
really be something neat to have at home
and it becomes a commercial product but
the basic science came out of the
military and so these kinds of exchanges
between government in the private sector
are essential and are under threat here
fortunately there's other parts of the
world that are picking up some of the
initiative and now that we have a global
economy again it's hard to tell
Americans this but you know there there
are certainly French corporations and
Chinese corporations in America but
they're all global corporations they all
do business everywhere and increasingly
it's hard to know where the company is
from based on where their capitalism
where their people that are and where
their products are being sold and so the
fact that the next solar power
initiative is probably gonna come out of
China is not a great threat to American
security it's it you know we're going to
be able to buy it because they're gonna
want to sell it to us so you know
capitalism may save us after all okay
let's see
getting technologies into the workplace
into people's daily lives is a challenge
one of the great successes in the last
twenty years is the cell phone there are
five billion cell phones on this planet
right now again here's a product twenty
years ago we didn't know we needed okay
and now people can't live without them
go to a teenager and tell them they
can't text message for a few hours and
see see whether this is a luxury or a
necessity but organizations are slow to
change let's let me try to skip through
here
there's a lot we don't know about
sustainability issues and so the idea
that there's going to be some huge
rational experiment to figure out
sustainable technologies is not the way
it's going to work we're going to try
some things we're going to fail we're
going to succeeded some other things
over time we're going to change the
technological base of our society okay
so those are the fundamental things I go
through in the book manufacturing which
basically talks about the integrating
into organizations what we call
industrial ecology trying to get
organizations to think about
sustainability issues as fundamental
management issues and this is happening
engineers are doing this already in a
lot of products on energy there so take
for example air conditioners or
refrigerators they use about a quarter
to a third of the energy they used ten
years ago now how did that happen it
happened because the engineers working
on the new product development we're
told start paying attention to how much
energy you music and one of the biggest
energy users in the American household
out is the box that includes your cable
channels and your DVR in fact I'm told
that it you that in some households it
uses more electricity than the
refrigerator and all the lights combined
ok it's a big energy user and it's on 24
hours a day somebody right now is
thinking about how do I create a cable
box that's more energy efficient and so
we're going to be doing more and more of
those things and that's happening
throughout businesses and businesses are
starting to look at energy in water as
cost of doing business in a way they
didn't look at before but it's some of
these technologies haven't been
developed and more of them need to be
the biggest problem in business is
business culture is organized around
short-term revenues and profits the
stock market the way to judge managers
the way we judge workers you know we're
still we're still managing our
organizations around the
of the year why the year the year is an
agricultural phenomenon has nothing to
do with an industry okay but we still
measure how our organizations perform
around that metric when in some cases
the appropriate metric might be three
years there might be six months but you
know this is how we do things and we
need to figure out ways of bringing
sustainability practices into the
routine decision-making of large
corporations and and and government
organizations okay
energy the u.s. system is all systems
are characterized by large-scale capital
e capital intensive centralized
facilities most some are nuclear and
hydro but most are fossil fuels
particularly of coal in this country
energy fossil fuels are still cheaper
than other forms of energy that is going
to start to change in Oriya starting to
change the pace of change is something
nobody really knows where and when these
tipping points will take place but they
will take place part of the issue is
attracting capital and here's a where
government plays a role capital always
goes after the highest rate of return it
doesn't care it's like water flowing
downhill okay it doesn't care really
what the product is or anything it cares
about what the rate of return is and so
in order for for rates of return to be
affected to drive capital into renewable
energy government has to intervene now
in this country that happened with
private homes before World War two
seventy-five percent of the people in
United States were renters today seventy
percent of the people the United States
are homeowners this change took place
because of two things the deductibility
of mortgage interest which started after
World War Two and the guaranteed loan
for more
which the the government decided to
guarantee and to ensure mortgages and so
suddenly you could buy a house with 10%
down or 20% down and so and you got a
tax deduction for your mortgage payment
which he didn't get on your rent and
suddenly we became a nation of owners
now why is that useful it creates a
middle class and a stake in property the
story I often tell there's this
development out in Long Island called
Levittown the Leviton was built in the
1950s there were three models of homes
there were just three different homes
now if you go to Levittown today because
people have built all sorts of additions
that are in and around their homes you
would never be able to tell that there
were three basic models it looks like
there were a hundred different models
because people put their sweat equity
and their excess capital into these
homes over time all of this was a result
of public policy pushing capital in a
particular direction that has to happen
in energy as well or it will be a very
long time before renewable energy
replaces fossil fuels now for some
people that might not be a bad thing
water and here most water goes into
farming farming is incredibly
inefficient and how it uses water and so
there that's the low-hanging fruit we
can figure out ways of creating
agricultural systems that use less water
the other thing is we need to be able to
invest in infrastructure to carry water
from places where we have too much of it
the places we have too little again in
the United States the city of Los
Angeles the City of Phoenix the City of
Tucson and the city of Las Vegas would
not exist or it not for a massive public
works project to take water from the
Rocky Mountains and bring it all the way
down to the Gulf of Mexico okay that
happened because of the federal
government and a massive public works
project without which those cities
simply could not exist they would have
exhausted their water supply many many
years ago so again we have the
technology the capital may not be there
and some of the wisdoms some of the some
of these some of the conduits for the
water
destroyed local environments and
probably could have been done more
effectively I think I'm gonna skip what
food I already made the point we have to
have industrial agriculture let me see
if I can get ok cities cities so in
about four years ago more than half the
planet for the first time lived in
cities there is this idea in the
environmental movement that somehow we
should live close to nature and spread
out among the planet if we did that we
would destroy the planet in fact the
answer to sustainability is greater
concentrations of populations so you can
build infrastructure to contain their
waste and to make them more energy and
water efficient and so in fact I don't
think I want to restart now maybe I'll
restart later ok so we hit so we we need
concentrations and we and cities are in
fact places where sustainability will
have to take place mass transit green
roofs tree planting parkland all of
those kinds of things the electric car
all that will ultimately make cities
even more inhabitable than they are
today now again this is a particularly
us issue because in the United States we
basically spread out among the
countryside everybody in America wants
to have their own acre of land in their
own home that isn't the aspiration of
people in other parts of the world
fortunately and decreasing as an appeal
here in the United States as people are
starting to see some of the benefits of
living in cities obviously we're going
to need to make the energy system more
efficient with smart grid electric cars
and we need the capital to do that the
problem in America is Americans are
under tax but they think they're
overtaxed and so how we're going to
solve that problem is not something I'm
going to get into today but there is a
there is a problem with that and then
for the whole planet part of it is we
need to be able to make sure the
technology
developed doesn't become a national
comparative advantage I don't believe
it's going to happen because of the
global cooperation I mean it's
interesting nation states still have a
hard time you know signing treaties and
agreeing with each other but
corporations do much better they buy
each other out they have local
subsidiaries we work with Pepsi on water
issues and Pepsi when they go into a new
country you know they buy a local
bottling plant they buy a water company
they you know you go to the forest
reaches of rural Africa and there'll be
a little refrigerator at the court at
this country store that Pepsi puts in
there and those Pepsi trucks somehow
make their way up these hills then
nothing else seems to be able to get to
okay so I believe that in fact American
and global corporations are going to
play a very important role in bringing
sustainability technology throughout the
whole economy okay can we manage this
complexity or with a modern economy
destroy the planet now that's really the
question it's gonna the world is getting
more complicated the technology and the
conditions are more complicated the
demands on management are becoming
greater and that's basically what my
book talks about is how do we create
sustainability managers the key
technological challenge I think is
energy the key financial challenge is
funding the capital cost of the
transition to green infrastructure short
term tangible impacts have more effect
and more political strength I mean this
is the problem with an issue like
climate climate is a problem that's
created everywhere and it's impacts are
in the future so politically it's
probably the worst case scenario if you
want to actually make something happen
and you take something like toxic waste
toxic waste happens locally it affects
people locally it's not hard to get
people motivated to do something about
it
okay those kinds of environmental issues
are very easy to get people to act on
climate isn't one of those
energy the issue of energy is going to
get addressed I think and the climate
issue will get addressed ultimately as
the price of energy goes up relative to
GDP and the price of energy is going up
relative to GDP right now and has been
for the last decade for two reasons one
is the long term price of energy the
other the GDP isn't growing as fast as
it used to and so the ratio is changing
one of the odds of success current data
says we're headed toward a catastrophe
if you look at the trend lines the
pictures not good but I think that we'll
figure it out I think that the young
people that I teach here and that I see
every day have internalized the
importance of these sustainability
issues they're not radical
environmentalists they don't want to sit
you know with nature all the time they
don't want to they don't want to reduce
their consumption but they understand
the challenges of continuing the
lifestyles we have and so I think I've
probably given you enough things to ask
questions about so I'd be happy to get
into a discussion about any of this
questions issues
yeah yeah the business school here
couldn't care less
the students can the some of the
students are attracted to these issues
but our business school well first of
all the Business School of Columbia is
totally focused on Wall Street I mean
it's basically that's where it's that's
where its graduates go and it's faculty
mainly care about that so when will know
that the world has really changed when
Wall Street starts paying attention to
sustainability issues and those students
suddenly start to say oh I better take
an issue of course on ecology but that
hasn't happened yet
well you know they're not see I think
they're going to be very poorly prepared
for this so we actually have other
programs through training managers and
it's actually one of the interesting
things the other thing this business
school doesn't do in most American
business schools doesn't doesn't train
people in the regulatory dimension of
business or politics
that's why sefa has been so successful
because well they don't do it we do it
we don't do management and finance as
well as they do but we do enough of it
and then we also teach people about
politics it's a very partial view I mean
actually the funny thing about the
business school here is they didn't do
international business until mayor
filbert became the Dean so have you
heard from out stepping yet okay so Al's
gonna come I was the Dean when I became
the curriculum Dean at seep in the 80s
and all the international business at
Columbia was in SEPA and we went over
and talked with them about trying to do
some things together and fell Berg
actually had as a priority changing it
but until then they only cared about
American business you know obviously
that's changed but and I think it'll
change on this too but they usually
change more slowly than the rest of the
world does let's put it that way
I think some of the larger corporations
are actually becoming change ages a
Walmart is probably in America one of
the best examples so Walmart is is as a
giant in terms of its relationship to
its suppliers they have a hundred
thousand suppliers and if you want to
sell to Walmart now you have to comply
with their sustainability indices you
have to report to them on how much
energy and water and waste are utilized
in what you produce they don't do that
because suddenly in Arkansas they've
discovered nature the thing they
discovered the green that they like in
Arkansas is the currency and and the
dollar and so what their so what happens
there this saves money I mean if you
think and I think that that's how it's
going to get into into organizations
more than anything else so Walmart's is
a good example also and that what is
Walmart in the business of selling it
basically leases its shelf space to
suppliers okay and so if the supply
could be concentrated and high
value-added they make more money per
square foot so they won't buy any
detergent for example that isn't highly
concentrated they because why should
they sell water okay they have the water
in the washing machine already and they
can make more money by having twenty of
these half gallons as opposed to you
know 10 gallons and that's how they do
it so that's gonna be one of the change
agents the other thing is I think a
perceptual change I think that most
people understand that the world is
getting more crowded than that resources
are becoming depleted and what I mean by
that is I mean in this country everybody
knows the place that they used to hike
when they were a kid that's now a strip
mall or is now a housing development
there it isn't hard and I think it's in
people's consciousness that the planet
is getting more crowded I mean I I mean
I'm 58 years old when I was growing up
there were 3 billion people on the
planet ok I remember when I wrote my
first what I wrote my dissertation which
was on citizen participation and
environmental policy in the mid 70s I
think there were four billion people on
the planet then and you know in another
couple of weeks we're going to be up to
7 billion those people have to go
somewhere I mean the idea that they have
no impact on resources or on the planets
ecosystem is just ludicrous it's not
that big oh it's big but it's not that
big so I think people understand that
and I think it's a combination of
economics of price of consciousness and
I think and of ideologies young people I
think have absorbed this and and the
messages are getting around the world
much much faster than they used to so if
you think about the impact of mass media
as being part of it
why did the you know what hasten the
demise of of of communism and of the
eastern of Eastern Europe part of it was
the images of wealth in Western Europe
but in the West it became harder to keep
out and to keep people from seeing it
one of my favorite stories of the
Khrushchev ear was he went home to he
took movies of him in Harlem to show how
badly Americans lived in there in
poverty and all people could talk about
was the nylons on the clotheslines and
the cars that were all over Harlem which
they didn't have back in Moscow at that
time so now the Internet provides images
that are free and accessible to people
in ways they've never been accessible
before and the impact of that pull
socially and politically is amazing we
see it socially when you get off the
plane in Bogota people teenagers are
wearing the same exact t-shirts that you
just saw them wearing in New York you
know and I'm sure you see the same thing
in London in Paris that you know there's
there's one world culture especially
among these kids and I think that that's
how the consciousness is going to change
and you see it happening rapidly
it's we haven't really seen its
political impact in America we saw it
with the Obama campaign Barack Obama
raised three hundred fifty million
dollars from the internet in
contributions of $50 or less never been
done before
totally overwhelmed the corporate money
at that point and totally surprised
everybody so we're seeing some so that's
that technology is having a political
impact that we can't really predict
right now well here's the fundamental I
guess the way I would put it and
actually you know what Moore's law is on
computers that every 18 months you know
that basically you're on a cost curve so
that the power the computer gets greater
and the price goes down well technology
has can have that impact if the cost of
raw materials is not central to the cost
calculus and so solar power will
eventually I don't know what eventually
will take place but will eventually be
cheaper than coal and other fossil fuels
and generating electricity just because
the price of the basic fuel is free okay
meaning the Sun so just a question of
the technological development of the
solar cell and the battery and the
distribution system so if you have
better distribution through a smart grid
you have a more efficient solar cell and
you have a more efficient battery system
but to store the energy if you have all
those things and again I'm not a
scientist I'm a political scientist but
I'm told by the people here who do that
work like Vijay Modi that in fact the
cost curve is get the solar power is
getting
less expensive from coming out of solar
cells that that it's a question of
technological development so that
technology will develop now in the case
of fossil fuel extraction there's also
been technological development okay
and so you are able to get to fuels you
couldn't get to before okay one of the
problems with some of it is that some of
its creating more ecological impact than
before so we had the Gulf oil spill we
also have things like hydro fracking
here or mountaintop removal good
technologies but not exactly good for
the planet
so the the true cost of that energy
production is not reflected in the cost
of the energy okay so and solar has some
problems with the cells themselves are
toxic and so you're gonna have to create
over time not just a more efficient
solar cell but a less toxic solar so but
again human ingenuity can go to work on
that problem we can't go to work on the
problem of fossil fuels because it work
you know eventually we use them I mean I
actually think 100 years from now people
are going to say you burn that stuff you
could have used it for plastics for this
and that this and that in production
instead you you burned it what was the
matter with you people
now this is this is a valuable one-time
resource of the creation of the planet
and even though if there's a lot of it
is that really the best use of it
particularly given issues like climate
change but even forget about climate
change just in terms of cost if we can
come up with a lower cost way of
generating electricity why wouldn't we
do it I think we will I mean I actually
think I mean I wrote about that today in
The Huffington Post I actually talked
about the about Steve Jobs and that
somewhere there's a there's a couple of
people working in a garage or a Shack
somewhere coming up with the answer to
these technological questions I hope I
also talked about you know it's hard
sometimes you don't want to use current
thinking to project the future so the
biggest environmental problem we had in
New York City in 1905 was horse manure
the city streets were loaded with it it
was just awful that we don't talk about
that anymore because the internal
combustion engine a technology nobody
expected got rid of all the horses okay
so we don't really know what the
technological futures
look like but but a solution that
focuses on using raw materials that are
natural resources versus one that allows
prices to go down because of Technology
and human ingenuity I think in the long
run it can only go in one direction it
might not be solely it could be a form
of nuclear that I mean you could create
a nuclear power that doesn't create a
waste and isn't doesn't create a bomb
that could that might be the answer I
mean we know that scientifically there's
infinite amounts of energy at the
subatomic level so you know virtually
infinite the point is there are other
technological solutions and I think that
in the long run and again how long and
how much damage so are we talking about
a hundred years we're talking about
twenty years we talk about 50 years I
think it's gonna happen but my colleague
class Lochner looking at this who says
we have to do everything and I don't
know if you guys get to meet class ok so
Klaus says we use more stones today than
we did during the Stone Age
we use more wood for fuel today that
when wood was the main form of fuel and
we'll use all the coal and all the all
the fossil fuels we can find for as long
as we can find them and that's why he
wants to do carbon capture and storage
and he's working on that pretty hard I
don't disagree with that but I actually
think that if you could find a cheap
form of generating electricity from the
Sun and it worked and and it could be
distributed widely and you had a way to
store and distribute it that solves the
problem and it solves the problem
without a lot of other complicated
technologies and when it gets to be
cheaper than coal and cheaper than oil
you probably won't use as much of that
stuff maybe you won't use it at all but
Klaus is right about the fact that the
technology overtime continues to always
use the old stuff even as you develop
the new stuff